uh my talk is like uh taking career to
the next level um I was thinking about
this talk as like things I would I would
have lik someone told me when I was at
like different parts of my career so I
hopefully have something interesting for
all of you to
take
so uh a bit introduction about me like
um I'm I'm again sahana I did my Ms in
um electrical engineering from
University of Southern
California um I currently uh I currently
live in the UK U I've lived across like
three countries so far UK us and India
and I believe that I have like up uh
their their values with me um I'm also
um senior machine learning engineer at
Jan Jaguar Lan Rover but I've also been
like data scientist at like a smaller
startups California based startups like
appeal Sciences who are series D and
impact wish who are like series um seed
level
startups so basically the talk I have
today was like kind of um thinking about
a career from holistic point of view um
it's up to us to basically make a career
not just about our jobs um a job is a
very important part of a career it's a
day-to-day work that's why we pick up a
lot of uh important skills
uh which we uh which we then use which
we then like keep on improving uh as we
move up the ladder but there are like
multiple other things we can do in our
site where we can uh enhance our
Technical and soft soft skills for
example site project side projects are
those projects where you can U make make
use of those make use of your time to
build that uh medium blog which you
liked a lot or this Tool uh you read
about in LinkedIn site projects from my
point of view teaches a lot about
accountability because nobody is there
looking out uh you need to basically uh
basically take accountability and like
work on it the other thing are online
courses Corsa name it Google have Google
has released their own own series of
online courses on J Amazon has done the
same these are all the cour which you
can take to enhance your particular uh
enhance the your knowledge in a
particular field um basically uh uh like
these online courses teach you a lot
about a discipline uh you need a lot of
discipline to like see a course through
um finally there's like the bit of uh
community of the other thing I want to
talk about is hackathons hackathons are
a way where you can like learn learn a
new skill in a very short amount of time
and also you learn a lot about teamwork
because you will be working with other
people and you'll also learn lot about
how to work with non- tech stakeholders
because some hackathon you'll be working
with people of of different skill
set uh this is a personal favorite where
I have learned a lot uh basically it's
Community volunteering a community
volunteering uh help puts you in a place
where you can like give back to that
community that has been supporting you
um I am a volunteer with woman or Cod
and through this I get to like uh meet a
lot of different people attend a small
workshops that helps me to improve uh a
field which I'm technically interested
in and also some of these communities
organize software soft skills based
workshops too that that is also a very
important skill to pick up a final thing
which is also a low hanging fruit is
meetups uh this this is this is not a
surprise that you find it here meetups
are the one of the easiest ways out
there to like uh meet somebody and and
learn about what's happening in a
particular company because a lot of
people are like very keen to share if
you are interested in it one of the the
one of the other reasons I found in my
career to focus on these other side
things not just my day-to-day job is uh
as you grow up in your career it it's
very hard to not tie your identity to
your job being in these uh be being in
this position where you like put your
put some amount of time in these side
things keeps you engaged in your the
field of Interest technically and also
uh puts you in a place where you can
make make connections and like grow in
your career and and basically come
basically choose your career because you
love it uh it helps me it has helped me
in my past to be more passion passionate
in my career when I'm like involved in
site things not just my job
related so I I am um um I'm a machine
learning engineer so basically the next
two slides are typically slightly
dedicated towards a a professional who
is uh trying to
seek trying to seek some uh insights
about like navigating their career path
in machine
learning for example uh in the umbrella
of machine learning has like so many
roles in it and it keeps on growing but
however I felt uh there are like three
different roles which you can which you
can bring about and which are distinct
from each other and they worth talking
about uh it's worth noting that a
different companies uh use these roles
interchangeably so you might need to uh
look deeply into the role description
what you're applying for and also
profiles of the people who are working
in that company company but um anyway to
keeping that aside and also the other
thing is that the the responsibilities
are not exactly the lines are not drawn
in like uh drawn in stone it can
basically can delineate it can there can
be a gray line but still uh like I
mentioned they are distinct enough the
first one I want to mention is like an
analyst role analist actually focus on
like building dashboards for their um
executive team and uh they they you they
normally need like deep understanding of
their businesses a strong analyst would
have like good visualization skills
domain knowledge and uh need to have a
really good communication because
they'll be talking to the executive
teams and help them in taking their uh
day-to-day decisions um data decision
scientist role decision scientists
normally work with like statistical
tools to provide uh recommendations or
insights to help again different
executive teams or the other teams to
take decisions based on the data
patterns and Trends the last one which
is something close to my heart is a
machine learning engineer a machine
learning engineer is somebody that who
combines the uh software engineering
skills with machine learning um creating
algorithms and model a good machine
learning engineer needs to have software
skills needs to be metric oriented
because you'll be developing systems
that run in real time you need to
understand what are the metrics that are
important to your stakeholders like uh
is it latency uh is it cost cost is an
important in like most of the businesses
and finally you'll be automating things
so you need to know the bigger picture
who would be using it How would how
would they be using it um I will
basically um in the next slide I want to
focus on like who what are the junior
senior and like lead expectations for
these different kind of roles um and
some one thing I want to mention before
I get started is that all of us have
like unique skill set and all of us
skill set are definitely valuable but uh
what I want you to take away from this
is not to be um intimidated because it
was even intimidating for me when I was
like trying to list on these skill sets
because in my head I was constructing
whether I have that or not but rather
you probably you have to read through
the skill set with a bit of empathy for
yourself see what
when some when some skill is of interest
to you maybe you can keep it in in your
side uh side burner to pick it up later
but just uh just have fun when I'm like
trying to describe about these junior
senior and Lead uh delineation for these
different roles the first one I want to
start with is an analyst um analyst a
junior analyst is expected to do a lot
of data collection basic analysis and
Report
generation as as you has to get more
senior they do more complex analysis and
they start managing uh small components
of larger projects or handle a a smaller
project on their own and when they get
to see uh lead level they their insights
uh would help in like taking Strate
strategic decisions for the company and
they would be demonstrating leadership
qualities like mentoring other Junior
analysts or helping non- Tech or non-
Tech stakeholders understanding the very
complex analysis uh decision scientist
uh so Junior decision scientist also
starts with like uh data collection
basic analysis and they start building
some basic statistical models as they
get more senior in their roles the
models get like more more complicated
and they start their models output will
start feeding into the Strategic
decisions a lead dat decision scientist
would build would be building
sophisticated models and would
participate in like high level strategic
meetings um the reason I like
highlighted these in like yellow is to
show that how similar things could be
Junior and senior and in lead level what
you need to take away from this is
basically um as you get higher up in
these analyst and decision science roles
you would start feeding in you'll start
feeding your inputs into the Strategic
uh planning basically driving the
business needs of the company uh mission
learning engineer Junior machine
learning engineer normally starts
working on small projects they um given
that it's a discipline that's between
software engineering and machine
learning you need to have a you need to
continuously build upon your programming
skills and your understanding of ml
Concepts a senior one would start seeing
um the life cycle of machine learning
products from design to development
would start mentoring other Junior
machine learning Engineers a lead would
be building like for example a system
architecture uh generic system
architecture that supports various
machine learning models not just the one
they have basically built and they would
be in a place to choose like what
technology or approaches would be
appropriate um
so moving on like uh the one other thing
uh I want to mention that is like
throughout the throughout the career
it's important to cultivate good
relationship with your stakeholders so
who are your stakeholders um
stakeholders could be the leadership
team for example we have seen that in
analyst and decision scientists would be
feeding their inputs to the executive
teams so executive teams don't have a
lot of time for you so you need to
basically uh find out ways to discuss
like complicated things with them that
resonates with their objectives and you
need to be to the point your managers um
you need to have a good relationship
with your manager overall no matter
which which role you fall into it's
important to collaborate with your
manager in your oneon-one share your
share your personal goals your
professional goals and uh help take
their help to see whether it's in
alignment with the Department level
group Department level goals business
stakeholders um this is also very
important a decision decision scientists
analysts or machine learning Engineers
we don't work alone we work on
collaboration and we tailor to the needs
of the company uh we need to we need to
understand what are the pain points of
the business itself uh understand which
B Which business challenge we can
contribute to and drive growth in so
that uh so this is basically talking to
all of the other team that sits
laterally with us identifying those
areas we can contribute to and finally
engineering teams uh engineering teams
here refers to like software Engineers
or data Engineers they are extremely
important and it's really important to
have a Synergy between machine learning
and these engineering teams so that we
can have collaborative workflows and we
can execute projects
successfully and uh on the same same
topic it's important um I found it in my
career that incorporating agile or
devops methodologies are like Version
Control uh helps a lot in a data science
project
um I found uh in my in my experience
that when you start like doing things
like code review document review the
time taken to actually deploy a
model it seems like we have some
internet trouble so let's let's see how
that
evolved um I hope that our speaker will
be just right
back um
yeah in the meantime question to you how
do you enjoy the session did you learn
something uh something new I'm opening
the mic right
now yeah hi uh Camila Claud here I would
just like to add like I like uh her
approach of um looking at it
holistically not only in terms of tech
like uh especially if you're starting
out where you don't have a lot of
experience you have to do some side
projects volunteering Community Building
like there's so many opportunities out
there to develop that experience even if
you don't work full-time so just wanted
to highlight those points which are I
thought were
interesting uh thank you so much for
Shing do you have your experience of
like situation maybe when uh that kind
of contribution helps uh in uh yeah sure
I'm I'm coming in from Dubai where I
work for about 10 years as an analyst I
would say in Dubai there's tons of
organizations and companies maybe we
don't have a lot of that startup energy
compared to the states San Francisco or
here right now I'm in Calgary in Canada
there's so much happening here as well I
would say if I had to restart again like
as a a younger data analyst and analyst
start doing community work volunteering
don't get stuck into one role and work
there for 5 years sometimes uh there's
more opportunities for learning more
opportunities to build communities and
you never know if the next job would
just be like a short Highway like hey I
need a uh someone to work in this role
for XYZ project and then you get a
basically your next job through
referrals and uh a lot of that actually
happens here in Calgary where I am now
um about 80 to 90% of the job market
here is hidden Market that means it's
through referral can agents hire people
they trust and they know they they have
work with so that's a challenge for
newcomers which is a bit it's a gap but
getting that Community experience
getting to work on side projects is just
yeah I would totally 100% agree on
that yeah wonderful uh thank you thank
you for sh that showing that I also have
very similar um experience like um with
with joining communities and also
building communities uh in in different
countries in different different cities
is something which
um brings uh in my career brings um a
lot of um enjoyment but also a lot of
knowledge a lot of this um sometimes
this knowledge which you will not learn
from books you will not learn from uh
courses it's uh it's just experience and
uh
is extremely extremely helpful and also
it's um let's say Pleasant in because
you you meet people you can learn from
people it's always more more joyful when
something is more joyful than than than
basically uh in my case also there is a
a great chance that I will just keep
doing that and be better in that because
because there is all this uh energy
there so um I totally totally can uh can
share this experience as
well yeah I see that uh our speaker that
Sana was trying to
join and she seems to
drop um yeah uh sometimes we we focus we
just um have this internet issues
unfortunately so so so sorry for that
but that's that's a great time for for
you to also share your stories like uh
so so so the question for now is like
what kind of stories what kind kind of
experience can you share about um
learning not only from job but but maybe
from Community or maybe from some Meetup
or maybe you have some other uh your
secret secret Source uh to to
learning so that's the open question
also there is a
question uh from
Aron about difference
in
okay great we have we have sahana
the I'm so sorry the I'm so sorry
everyone like my laptop stopped
working can I
continue uh yes sir no worries great
having you back and please continue
thank you for being so understanding
everyone awesome um yeah so I'll just
start with the second Point like um it's
it's important I found in my career to
adopt these agile or devops
methodologies because uh they help to
basically bring development deployment
faster that's something a lot of
companies have struggled with and have
found answer in adopting these
techniques the last one is to have um
empathy and effective Communications um
I I found when I was when I'm working
with like non-tech St stakeholders to be
to employ empathy and be clear and
concise about uh what are basically the
handoff points or what are they looking
for um this I found is it takes a lot of
a lot of practice and uh it's very
important to be understand that the
domain experts need not be data science
experts and uh we need domain knowledge
knowled to build better models so yeah
it's important to be keep the
communication clear and be EMP uh employ
a lot of empathy in it um moving on to
the uh next slide uh it's this is also
something I found uh extremely useful in
my career is basically employ seeking
mentors and sponsors um mentors are
mentors are those people who can give
you advice on like guidance on Career
decisions what kind of skills you should
be picking up how to have a work life
balance um there they are needed for
both developing Technical and
non-technical skills me mentors are
normally found in your companies and
like you can seek your senior people to
be mentors or some non Tech related
people to be mentors as well in my
career when I was like looking through
job opportunities or like trying to
enhance my skill set I went for like
paid
mentorship as a person who has worked in
startups this paid mentorship helped me
to really understand what these big Tech
big Tech uh data science teams and
machine learning teams are seeking and
help me to develop my technical skills
in more goal oriented way sponsors are
those people uh normally uh or people in
a who are who are in a position of power
uh who can Advocate things for you
within your company like a promotion or
or a race uh sponsors can also be people
who are found outside your company and
uh they could help you with like getting
some conference tickets Etc sponsors are
like somebody who not just advise you
but also advocate for you and it's more
if if not equally but more important to
find sponsors for you because they are
the ones who will be opening up doors
for you which which otherwise could be
unclosed which otherwise would be closed
um one thing one way to cultivate or
find the sponsor us is like putting you
putting yourself out there in these
meetups or volunteer settings
approaching people um you don't need to
be you don't you you don't need to be
very straightforward with them but
genuinely try to understand who they are
uh you would be very surprised to see uh
how many people will volunteer thems
because everybody most of the times in
my experience I found in tech people are
genuinely trying to help each other out
and uh finally I'm going to probably um
end this by say sharing couple of
resources that are close to my heart
like the first one how to have a career
in data science by Jaclyn Norris and
Emily Robinson it was um as somebody who
has worked from like startups and mnc's
I found a lot of things that are
discussed in this book extremely
extremely uh instructional to whoever
whatever place they are in their career
um it's very very rare to find that book
that goes into detail like what kind of
what kind of skill set that a startup uh
expects versus what kind of skill set
which which a established team would
expect I I honestly when I read this
book I felt I felt like I should have
brought this book years ago when I was
like fresh out of
school um I I mentioned that I used paid
mentorship uh when I was seeking through
job opportunities there's Danley in
mentors these are places where you can
like pay and seek mentorship and like
those skill set which you want to uh be
more proficient in it could be data
science skills or machine learning
skills and finally uh something that's
of a lwh hanging fruit is like YouTube
tutorials or podcast um Tina hung is
like somebody who I follow basic she
discusses like a lot of things Technical
and non-technical things that do that
help me a lot um
and also chai time is data science this
is very very casual setting where data
scientists and like other people come in
and discuss about their workf flow um it
just informs you like what are the other
what are the other roles out there what
are the other companies out there what
are they doing how are they doing it and
in a very casual way which I like it
these are the things I use but I think
they like tons of resources out there in
LinkedIn um well that's pretty much what
I have
I'm happy to I'm sorry for the for the
disruption in the middle but I'm happy
to take any
questions there is definitely this uh
this question uh from the chat from um
Aron and the question is what what would
be the difference between working for a
startup and company in the data science
field that's a that's a great question I
feel like I can speak from my own
experience um in a startup the roles are
not uh roles are not like delineated uh
in my experience you have to be prepared
to wear different hats as your business
needs it because as a when I was working
in a very seed level startup sometimes I
had to be the software engineer because
people there was no software engineering
team sometimes you need to be that uh
business person who talks to your non uh
non- Tech customers and help them like
understand your the problem they're
trying to solve in details and in
addition to that you need to be a data
scientist um I also feel like in in
startup basically we are trying to uh
deliver products quickly but not don't
have a lot of um in a very small startup
you try to deliver products quickly you
don't have like a very solid practices
in place as you as you get as you get
employed in a bigger bigger company
there are um there are definitely more
solid practices in place that helps you
with your onboarding your career
progress Etc but the catch is you don't
get to see the impact of your work as
easy you would see in a seed level
startup so it's something to uh look
for uh wonderful
that there is uh there is also the
question about your slides uh are you
comfortable with sharing your slides
maybe for this uh select channel that
will be the easiest way yeah yeah of
course
perfect do we have any other question we
still have some time um
yeah um if not I'll put my LinkedIn also
feel free to like reach out in the slack
Channel or LinkedIn with any
questions yeah your presentation was uh
was great thank you so much for sharing
thank you for sharing your experience uh
it's very uh very useful very um very
thoughtful as well
um there is a question uh two Grant
programs
uh um greatly impact your career growth
that's the next question that's a great
question to ask um I would say like
three or four years ago uh Master
degrees were like must for or seen as
must for people in data science course
uh that's where you were going going and
that's what I did like I went to a grad
school and that helped me to understand
techniques and programming skills and
help me to get a job but that trend is
changing right now they're like so so
many boot camps out there and I've
personally heard success story of those
people who were basically teachers and
this they did a boot camp and now they
are like back in software Engineers
they're like different different
different boot camps for different
different uh purposes is but I think
those are also those are also something
that you could look into so to answer
your question grb program helped me but
it's not fair to say that's it's needed
for everybody who tries to break into
this
field it's amazing like uh how how fast
things are changing
yeah yeah totally uh I also had some
experience like not myself but but like
have other experience from people who
didn't graduate in programming but
definitely they get a very good PID job
and great career in programming after
after some boot camps actually boot
camps are are really uh cool in the way
that if boot camp has some uh some uh
internship program after uh that's also
your foot in the door and sometimes it's
the the hardest part so if you can
afford with your time to to just be part
of the boot camp so be there like half a
year one year then then they can help
you with with some internship which will
give you the good
start
yeah I also think that maybe this is
also uh good good point to think about
is that um boot there right now the
frankly the immigration policies of
different countries have not caught up
with it yet like boot camp gives you the
knowledge but it doesn't give you more
like for example in the states work
rights as much as a grad program would
give you like the stem op Etc there's
also something to think
and like as as people are working with
the policy some things to think take
into consideration when you're like
planning your career longterm which
would strengthen your position in that
country that's excellent point like uh
if if you are planning to live in
different country than than the your
original country or of country of born
that that's something which you need to
consider and it's not something which
you will hear many like conversation
about and it's very very
true yeah well please plan to
that okay
wonderful uh thank you so much for this
amazing talk um I I hope that you will
be also available on slack for some
other
questions course I'll share the slides
shortly
there perfect thank you thank you so
much for that uh for the impact program
that's the last session for for today we
are we are we have this strong uh ending
of of the day now please uh join us
tomorrow and
uh uh yeah please share your LinkedIn on
the slack please be connected and stay
connected and yeah see you on the next
session see you tomorrow have a
wonderful and Day evening uh um yeah and
see you around